I always find the idea of the next
project most interesting thing is there
ever is one you're always nervous but
well we have we're lucky enough to work
on a very big scale in a very small
scale so we like working for null as
we're doing furniture in a very small
scale a chair a chair is the hardest
thing to do because it stripped down to
the very basic thing its lack of
ornament it has to function it has to
have a ergonomics and it involves a kind
of three-dimensional exploration that is
very disciplined and also delivering it
a certain costs and for a certain thing
is a very interesting challenge a faucet
for water works Peter had worked on
inventing new valves for water works and
it's that kind of thing from we're doing
a museum now and lots of residences all
over the world and corporate work and
hotels and stuff like that but so I'd
say every challenge is interesting and I
wouldn't it's a continuum of a whole
thing we've done an airplane we've done
an ocean liner all kinds of things and
each one represents different challenges